♪♪
-Hey, everybody.
Okay, so in the credits
last week, we...
had a credit that said
the show was produced
by the O'Reilly Crime Syndicate.
That was, of course,
a reference to the family
that is really running things
here in the building.
I know O'Reilly is not
their real last name...
[ Laughter ]
...but I have used
their real last name
in the past,
and when I did...
I was told in no uncertain terms
[Irish accent] to never use
the real name, boyo.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
And I was not told politely.
[ Laughter ]
Let me make clear.
Walking down the hallway
after a show,
all of a sudden
the lights go off...
bag over my head.
And I knew it was them, because
there were like 20 of them.
It's like 40...rough hands
giving me the business.
The message was received
is all I'm saying.
You might be wondering,
"Oh, Seth, you have security.
Where it was John?"
Where was John...O'Malley?
[ Laughter ]
Would you believe he had
a "family emergency" that day?
Pretty convenient.
[ Clears throat ]
We showed
this Amelia Earhart statue
from Purdue University.
You can see the name there.
This actually --
Someone at Purdue said
it's actually
right outside Earhart Hall.
It's a residence hall.
I guess
it's one of the nicest ones.
Only problem -- hard to find.
[ Laughter ]
I said it was
a little troubling
they made a statue of her where
she's holding a very important
part of the plane.
But I guess this was a --
this is a famous moment,
one of her favorite --
one of her famous quips.
She was also known --
She is known as
"the Oscar Wilde of the skies."
And she was walking
by holding this.
Legend goes...
Someone said,
"Hey, Amelia, don't you
need that for your plane?"
And she said, "Oh, this?
No, this is just a prop."
[ Laughter ]
We talked about
how the MGM lion roar
is actually a tiger roar
because the tiger
sounds fierce in a way
we, the audience,
expect a lion to sound.
A jackal reached out to say
not only that,
when you hear an eagle scream
in a commercial, film,
television,
they're actually using
the sound of a red-tailed hawk.
I looked this up.
I confirmed this.
Because an actual bald eagle
sounds like a squeegee.
So I was curious to hear
what that would sound like.
Let's take a listen.
-[ As Andrew Squiggman ]
Hello!
-Oh, a Squiggy.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
I read that --
I read that one wrong.
Let's just get through the --
my worst part of the week.
I have said --
[ Laughter ]
I have said time and time
and time again,
don't use the P.O. box to send
me Mac Tonight merchandise.
Okay?
It's like the one thing
I don't want.
And it keeps showing up.
Actually, it's not.
I want to reiterate.
It's not
the one thing I don't want.
There's two things
I want you to send me --
Mac Tonight merchandise
and Fabergé eggs.
[ Laughter ]
So I'm going to show you
this week's haul
in a reverse order
of how distressing I found it.
I don't -- I don't care for this
jacked blue guy at all.
[ Laughter ]
I don't -- This looks like...
looks like he'd have his way
with you.
Um, this -- Look.
This is impressive
craftsmanship,
but this isn't a piece of rock
art I know what to do with.
I don't care for the fact
that it's holding
in a mug that says
Wally down by its crotch.
[ Laughter ]
Again, I appreciate the time --
I don't like
when you make it me.
I don't like that.
That's worse.
It's worse when it's me.
And I know a lot of you think
to overcome my fears,
I have to become them.
Or at least I guess that's
the message of this nightmare.
[ Laughter ]
And then...this came.
It's like Happy Meal toys,
right?
And you might be like,
"Hey, Seth,
that seems less distressing
than everything else
you've show me."
Well, here's the thing,
you guys.
it came
with this card that says,
"Congratulations
on your new home."
[ Laughter ]
Like, I guess implying
they [bleep] know where I live?
[ Laughter ]
It's like Mac
from [bleep] "Watcher."
[ Sighs ]
I was sent one other
Mac Tonight-themed thing,
and it is, no exaggeration, too
distressing to show on TV...
...and I know it is
too distressing
because I showed it
to someone at NBC Standards,
and exactly a week after I
showed it to them, they died.
[ Laughter ]
And they know it was
Mac Tonight related,
because they did an autopsy
and they died from
an overdose...
of Filet-O-Fish.
They had two.
[ Laughter ]
And you might be like,
"Seth, you saw it.
Obviously, you had to see it
before you showed it
to the person
at NBC Standards.
Like, how come you didn't die?"
I feel terrible to say this.
I think I lived because
I showed it to someone else.
[ Laughter ]
So, if you ever see it
for a quarter of a second...
make sure you show it
to someone else.
Um...
Bathrooms don't echo.
They reverberate.
[ Laughter ]
Um...
Echoes gets smaller
with each successive one.
I guess when I did my echo,
I didn't get quieter.
So to the person who said that,
I just want to say
you're annoying, you're
annoying, you're annoying...
[ Laughter ]
Um, Marjorie Taylor Greene
couldn't kick open
a bathroom door like a saloon
because they only open in.
Don't count her out.
[ Laughter ]
George Santos lied about playing
volleyball at Baruch College.
I said Baruch College
isn't exactly renowned
for its volleyball program.
One of you took offense
and said --
and these are their words --
"Baruch College has won
their league pretty regularly
and had some moderate
post-season success."
[ Laughter ]
So I stand corrected.
What I should have said
was Baruch College
isn't exactly renowned
for its volleyball program.
[ Laughter ]
We talked about Biden
maybe having secret documents
from his time in the Senate,
which started in 1973.
We joked that
he would be listening
to classified 8-track cassettes.
We referenced Blue Oyster Cult's
"(Don't Fear) The Reaper."
Well, a bunch of
Blue Oyster Cult superfans,
otherwise known
as the Blue Oyster Cult...
[ Laughter ]
...they reached out to say
that song was from 1976,
and Biden, again, as we
established, started in 1973.
I kind of thought
it was within the realm
that it didn't have
to be the first year,
but I guess I should
have dug harder...
found a song from 1973.
So, if you want to take this
and you can edit it
into that "Closer Look" for
when you go back to watch it...
since you're so [bleep] upset
about it...
[ Laughter ]
"Ah, this...
Leroy Brown guys sounds bad.
'Bad' bad."
[ Laughter ]
We showed our favorite video
that we often show --
Joe Biden
tripping up the stairs.
And our joke was if you showed
that video -- because, again,
we're taking note
of the fact
that it's so hard to figure out
how you can trip up --
if you showed that video
to Isaac Newton,
he'd burn up his notebooks
and start over.
Some of you said
it would be more likely
that if we showed that video
to Isaac Newton,
he would freak out
over video technology.
You might think, but all he
cared about was gravity.
It didn't matter
how it was packaged,
he just focused on the gravity.
If a naked woman fell from
the sky and landed in his lap,
all he would care about
was that she came straight down.
You know, he was not liked...
by the mathematicians
of his era...
because they also knew
the whole time
that if an apple fell,
it would fall down.
And they didn't realize
that if they told somebody that
they'd be known
as the father of gravity.
[ Laughter ]
So he was formally known
as Sir Isaac Newton,
but to them, they called him --
behind his back, of course --
No [bleep] Newton.
[ Laughter ]
I guess a couple of weeks ago
we talked about
Norwegian tourists
in Times Square looking
for the M&M's store, and...
well...
someone from Norway
took offense at...
the grammar we claimed
Norwegians would have
if they were speaking English.
"Dear Seth, you had a bit
where you did
a Norwegian impression,
and it was disappointing.
I think you missed the accent,
but more troubling
was the grammar.
Even those Norwegians
with heavy accents
are likely to be very
comfortable with the language.
Consider Jens Stoltenberg,
sexy General Secretary --
Secretary, sorry,
General of NATO
and former
Prime Minister of Norway
as a possible example.
Thank to you
for be reading this.
May up be the place.
You keep the good work."
So, it fell apart at the end.
[ Laughter ]
We showed a video
last "Corrections"
proving that when the Roadrunner
says "meep, meep"
it's not the noise it's making,
it's the WB censors
meeping them out.
And we got our hands
on an uncensored version,
and we showed that when
the "meep, meep,"
you hear it on screen,
what the Roadrunner was actually
saying was "[bleep] off."
And a bunch of you asked,
"Why would the 'off' be meeped?
Why wouldn't it be 'meep off'?"
Well, you obviously
don't have kids
because if it's "meep, meep,"
you can tell the kids
that's the sound
the Roadrunner's making.
If it's "meep off,"
then they want to know
what the meep is for, right?
And then the whole day,
they're like,
"What's the meep?
What's the meep?"
And you're like, "It's not
for you. It's only for adults."
And they're like, "We want to
know! We want to know!"
And then eventually you hit
your breaking point
and you tell them
to [bleep] off.
[ Laughter ]
Someone wrote, "In real life,
coyotes catch and eat
roadrunners all the time."
Cool.
[ Laughter ]
Pass that on to my friends
at "Looney Tunes."
[ Laughter ]
I said
someone knit me this jackal,
when it is clearly "cro-cheted."
[ Laughter ]
Uh, complaint.
Not a correction,
a complaint...
that I've stopped doing
my Al Pacino impression.
And it's true.
There was a time
when I was doing it
with great regularity,
but that time has passed.
I think of my impressions...
not as voices I'm doing...
...but rather tiny people
who are inside me,
using me as a vessel
to tell their stories.
And when they've told
their stories,
I think it is best to move on
so it doesn't hinder
my own personal growth.
So with my Pacino,
as much as it pained me...
to do so...
it was time...
to say goodbye
to my little friend.
[ Laughter ]
Someone wrote, "Correction --
you don't give penicillin
for gonorrhea,
but they do usually
give one dose of ceftriaxone."
And that one was sent
to us by...
anonymous.
[ Laughter ]
Let's see.
Is there anything else?
-[ Shrieking ]
-Seven days!
[ Laughter ]
I feel very confident
that this will be
our most watched "Corrections."
[ Laughter ]
Or else there are going to be
a lot of dead jackals!
See me next week!